hi my name is josephine langford hi i'm
hero find stiffen and we're here to read
first tweets about tessa and hun
after we fell is by far the best movie
in the after series and seeing hardin
actually trying to be better was so good
you can finally see the growth with
harden and tessa as people after the
cabin scenes love that for them i do
love that for them yeah this is a pretty
tame first treat i saw you can finally
see the growth and then i got a bit
worried and then yeah it went back to
being pretty tame so uh yeah i feel like
we were all conscious of of trying to
make
you know hardin's trying to be better
and and trying to trying to demonstrate
their growth so i'm glad that i'm glad
that the fans saw that from molly on
hardin's lap to test on hardin's lap the
blower undeniable
oh
inanna is a beautiful beautiful woman
yeah but it's molly and tesla isn't it
it's molly and tessa so yeah uh yeah
even in the pictures you can see one of
them is just it's just it's meant to be
the glow up is undeniable
robert is a good guy but anyone that's
around tessa that isn't han can eat dirt
and choke
i agree wholeheartedly carter's a lovely
guy i wouldn't want him to eat dirt and
chunk but robert can eat all the dirt in
the world i still remember when harding
called tessa tess for the first time i
got goosebumps it was too cute oh i
don't i don't remember that is there
like a iconic scene where he says like
this for the first time no i don't i
don't think so i think that they're just
saying that it was very memorable
thank you watching after again and how
blessed are we that we got joe and hero
as our perfect tesseran harden i still
get butterflies watching the first movie
oh these are very
so sweet these are very very tame and
sweet yeah these aren't thirsty i hope
we don't go from like zero to a hundred
on the next one but yeah it's that's
lovely to read isn't it thank you guys
tessa sitting on harding's lap is
probably one of my favorites ever they
like that one don't know that scene was
good though that scene was because i
know what they mean with the comparison
to how it was with molly before it works
very well and then everything that
follows on from that is very
entertaining hard in writing i love you
on tessa's back in the bath is the
softest thing ever i'm crying i remember
doing that
yeah that was sweet wasn't it i think we
were just genuinely you were writing
stuff and i was trying to guess it yeah
you know what i definitely prefer that
bathtub scene to the hot tub scene
the hot tub it was uh
negative zero degrees and it was so cold
that we were told
it was we were gonna we had to have a
medical doctor on set and that we
probably weren't gonna make it through
the night uh and a genuinely warm bath
inside uh was definitely nicer than a
freezing cold hot tub outside in
bulgaria in the winter tester and
hunting really sneaked into the library
all cute and he read a story and they
cuddled and somehow had to run from
someone after being caught this scene is
cute as
i've really liked what um what tom did
with with the direction of saying um
harding should like jump at the barrier
in a very like you know masculine cool
parkour kind of way and then tessa just
walks right through it because it's not
locked
i love that little direction every time
i rewatch the club scene i get
butterflies from the way hardin looks at
tessa please oh
yeah oh indeed no wonder tis
no wonder tessa could never say no to
harden i couldn't deny him either these
are all like pixelated silhouettes
i love that they've included photos
[Laughter]
if my future husband doesn't look at me
the way hardin looks at tessa i don't
claim him a lot of the movie is hard and
giving smoldering gauges towards tesla
isn't it how do you feel about
seeing photos of you doing like
smoldering gazes um
do you know what yeah i'm so sad and
annoyed and disappointed in myself to
say i'm kind of just used to it
yeah cool hess's hot scenes are amazing
but has his cute scenes come on you guys
just perfection i'm glad that you find
hester's hot scenes amazing but our cute
scenes
perfect because we work really hard and
to think that you find you think they're
perfect it's like
that's great so thank you hopefully we
should get some more cute scenes out
there because um we made an effort to
kind of try and try and demonstrate more
of the you know
nicer parts of their of their
relationship a lot of them in the third
one would be for me as well like the one
i don't know if it even made it but we
did some stuff like they're making a
cake i remember this flower water and an
egg and we were told to like improv just
a quick little scene and that it was
going to be used in a montage and i'm
like what on earth are we making with
flour water and an egg the amount of
money i'd pay to get the script and see
what has the moments were unscripted
please how much i feel like we stuck to
the script a fair bit um with this one
but we kind of we're kind of i feel like
just developing it as it goes like we
almost like script something a week and
a week in advance would that be scripted
or unscripted and finally the final
tweet tesla on his damn lap hardened
caressing her leg tessa touching his
tattoos i'm freaking dead over here
hashtag off the movie i know these are
filtered but i think it says a lot that
people really respond
to
the non-sexual moments of intimacy in
these films like less is more it's like
just give them a bit and let the rest be
you know yeah i i agree i feel like
those when you're kind of on the line
that's that's uh that's what people
respond to almost a lot more and we have
love buzzfeed's first tweets thank you
so much for your tweets and make sure to
see after we fell streaming on october
19th
[Music]
uh